I want to tell you a little story of when I was growing up and working on a farm in Canada.
One of the farmers I was working for had a gopher problem, they were everywhere.
Thousands of them. And what he had me do was get a little bit of grain and add some
anti-freeze to it, and mix the two together.
Then we would place these by the gopher holes and they would eat it,
and they would eventually die.
Which brings me to the point guys, this stuff is extremely toxic and it tastes very sweet.
So if you have animals in the house, and anti-freeze lying around, they will lick it up, and they will die.
So please be extremely careful, if you ever try and do any experiments with anti-freeze.
So I was still getting tons of requests in the comments for liquid nitrogen experiments
And as I was scrolling through today I found this comment from "Sagisu12" that says:
"Can you freeze anti-freeze in liquid nitrogen?"
That's a really good question, will anti-freeze freeze?
Over 800 of you thumbs up this comment so apparently it's something you really want to see.
So I went and picked up some ethylene glycol so we can put that suggestion to the test.
So in preparation for this experiment today, I did a little research on anti-freeze,
and beside from the fact that it is extremely poisonous,  it actually has a really wide operating range.
It can get as hot as about 130ºC and as cold as -37ºC.
And I'm saying Celsius for all you international viewers out there. Give me a thumbs up if you appreciate that.
Will this stuff actually freeze, will it gum up, will it turn into kind of a slime or a gel or will it turn into like a frozen crystal anti-freeze?
That's the purpose of this experiment today! Let's find out what anti-freeze does in liquid nitrogen.
Now for this demonstration I thought it will be fun to use this curious looking little dish here.
This is called a quaich and it comes from my good friend George Calver from Scotland, so thank you
George. We'll be putting this to good use today, with anti-freeze and liquid nitrogen.
Let's get started
That is so pretty
It's so beautiful
That, my friends, is what anti-freeze looks like
But you would not want to put this in your mouth, it's extremely poisonous
As good as it looks,
don't drink it!
Because the way that this is kind of shining it does make me wonder
What if we took a UV flashlight to it?
Wow! That is really cool!
That is neat!
A little UV light and some anti-freeze and you've got a homemade glowstick
Who knew?
You can control your glowstick
[chuckles]
Now this fluid is really curious and I thought it would actually be a lot thicker
more like glycerin
but if you look at it, it flows kind of like water
But if I put my finger in and just kind of swish it around,
it feels more like a watery, sugary syrup.
It's very viscous
So let's get into our experiment. Liquid nitrogen, glass dish, here we go.
There we go!
Look at that bubbling.
For as many times as we've used this glass dish
I'm amazed it hasn't cracked by now.
[Chuckles]
It's held up really really well!
This happens every time!
Like, as the liquid nitrogen has almost cooled the glass down in temperature,
it starts rapidly boiling! It gets very violent and
usually spills everywhere
Oh yeah, there it goes! Look at all the skittles!
Look how much nitrogen it has taken to cool this dish down!
This was filled up more than half-way, and now it settled down to about
a quarter, of the glass!
So,
the difference is now the glass is really cold, and we can add more nitrogen to it.
This nitrogen is homemade, fresh out of the dewer this morning
Perfect!
So looks like our dish is ready, let's go ahead and
lower the quaich.
Alright, moment of truth guys!
This is pure antifreeze
First test is 100% antifreeze
Let's see how that reacts
I'm kind of, like, a little bit nervous
Cuz this dish is warm compared to that nitrogen
Woah! My gloves froze!
And there goes the-- Ha!
I kinda knew that was gonna happen
But look down here, look down here at the bottom
You can actually see
The antifreeze--is kinda like balling up
Bubbling around
That was a total fail
And my shirt is cold
But we still get to see what's happening here
If you look at the antifreeze, it looks like
It is turning into some kind of a--
Slightly greenish gel
But is it gel or is it solid?
If you look at the slo-mo, you can see it
actually froze my fingers,  like the gloves,
the tips of my fingers froze solid
And so I had to let it go
Liquid nitrogen repels off of the skin faster
when you don't have any gloves, like by wearing gloves
It actually freezes solid and keeps the cold in contact with my skin
So having gloves with liquid nitrogen may be counter-productive.
Oh yeah, look at that
It's beautiful
It's very, very pretty and it was totally an accident.
yep that's super hard
Look at this stuff down here
I'm in need of some way to scoop that out
Woah, yeah look, it froze my fingers solid
it just takes an instant
Oh! That's cold!
Ha!
*spoon clinks*
Look at this chunk in here--
Oh yeah, there's a nice, healthy chunk of antifreeze right there
That is definitely solid
WOAH!
Ah, it's freezing my fingers!
It like, busted away like breakaway glass,
and then it stuck to my fingers and cryogenically froze them
like a cryogenic napalm
That is nasty stuff!
You can't get it off very easily because it's very sticky.
This stuff will actually crush up into a powder, check this out--
So check this out guys, we have just created--antifreeze snow.
Oh look, it's dripping!
It's like, warming back up and turning into slime!
Anti-frozen slime!
Aw, you can mush it, you can mold it, you can sculpt it!
It's like gel, and it's a little bit translucent, so it kinda looks like--
The ninja turtle ooze I made out of borax
in one of my other videos
This stuff is starting to warm up, and it's actually turning opaque, which is really interesting
like, the warmer it gets, the more cloudy it gets
kinda looks like a lime sorbet
I wonder what it smells like
It has a slightly sweet smell, for the most part i would say you can't really smell anything
What does it taste like?
Just joking!
*laughs* we're not gonna taste it, ok
So we have a little leftover nitrogen in the container here,
what would happen if we poured that directly into a cup of antifreeze itself?
Let's find out!
Ohhh cool!
Look at the top here, check this out
So the nitrogen actually floats on the top of the antifreeze
and then it forms like this little crusty layer
That's bizarre, it's like making little islands of ice in there
We'll do a litle bit more this time
Yeah, so the nitrogen floats on top of the antifreeze,
And then it freezes it, this crusty layer on top.
It's almost like a poisonous creme brulee.
Let's poor in the rest of it.
*chuckles* almost immediately, the top crusts over with ice
Or whatever that is, ethylene glycol
So if you look in here you can see the antifreeze,
is almost untouched on the bottom, but then it freezes and forms a layer here,
and we have nitrogen bubbling on the top.
So, we have like, frozen antifreeze--
And as it thaws it'll form this very viscous, slimy kinda syrup.
Let's make it like a frozen pond of antifreeze.
So update, guys, we know antifreeze by itself will freeze completely solid,
but according to the container here, if we add 30% water, that will give us maximum efficiency.
So I filled up a container here with a little less than 1/3 of a cup of water,
and so if we fill it the rest of the way with antifreeze,
we should theoretically have a 70 30 mix,
and we can see how that reacts.
A solution of antifreeze and water has a very wide temerature range
and that's very important because most automobile engines are water cooled.
If you just use water by itself, there's a couple problems you might run into:
if it gets too cold, the water can freeze and turn into ice and clog up your radiator,
and if it gets too hot it can flash into steam and cause extreme damage to the engine itself.
But by adding antifreeze to the coolant, you can now widen the temperature range
because it has a much lower freezing point and raises the boiling point dramatically at the same time.
So in the interest of conserving my precious homemade liquid nitrogen,
I'm gonna pour it into the quaich here and let that cool down
and then we'll take this antifreeze-water solution and just slowly poor it in so we can see the reaction close up.
Ok, so here we go, our quaich has cooled down, we got little bits of my glove floating around in there
Let's go ahead and take our antifreeze-water solution and just drip it down inside.
Here we go!
Aw, sweet!
It's like bubbling on the top, and then it sinks to the bottom.
Will it freeze, that is the question.
Now I'm not expert, but I can clearly see the answer is yes.
Look at that.
It's like made a bubble.
It's almost hollow on the inside, it's made a bubble of water and antifreeze.
Whoops!
It's very very fragile, apparently.
I'm just gonna drip this stuff in slowly and see if that makes any difference.
Now, that is kinda cool
For a second, it seems the antifreeze just kind of--
bubbles and floats on the top.
Now check this out--
That is neat!
That looks pretty freakin' cool.
Ohh, did you see that bubble just squirt out?
While you're looking at that, I'm gonna put some UV light on it.
Oooooh
Look at the way that just lights up
Woah
After this stuff is frozen solid, it kinda looks like crystals of kryptonite.
Yeah, that's definitely rock hard.
Adding water is still no match for liquid nitrogen.
So will liquid nitrogen freeze antifreeze?
I think the answer is apparent--yes, it will. And we had a lot of fun doing it today.
We also made antifreeze snow--I didn't even know you could do that--and found that
UV light will make this stuff light up like a glowstick.
All super cool experiments, and all because you asked for them.
And good thanks to Sagisu12 for suggesting this experiment today
and all 814 of you that thumbs up-ed that comment.
Keep an eye on your youtube inbox, Sagisu, and I'll send you 25 bucks.
And thanks to all you guys for hanging out with me today! I'll be looking for you in the next video.
Talk to you then.
*punch sound*
I think this thing is actually stuck to my workbench.
I can't get it up!
*crack*
*punch sound*
*music*